AREA.
HE HAS PROVED TOTALLY UNWILLING
TO EVEN GET ANYWHERE NEAR THAT.
THANK HEAVENS.
ON TWITTER YOU MAY READ FORMER
CIA HAD JOHN BRENNAN SPOUTING
OFF ABOUT THE POLITICAL NEWS OF
THE DAY, ATTACKING THE
PRESIDENT'S DISHONESTY HE SAYS.
IT TURNS OUT BRENNAN HIMSELF IS
A LIAR.
HE'S BEEN CAUGHT LYING, ODD FOR
A GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL.
LAST YEAR FOR EXAMPLE BRENNAN
TOLD CONGRESS THE INFAMOUS
STEELE DOSSIER HAD NO INFLUENCE
AT ALL ON THE CLAIM THAT RUSSIA
INTERFERED IN THE 2016 ELECTION.
HERE'S A SELECTION.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHO COMMISSIONED
THE STEELE DOSSIER?
>> I DON'T.
>> DID THE CIA RELY ON IT?
>> NO.
>> MIGHT NOT?
>> BECAUSE IT WASN'T PART OF THE
CORPUS OF INTELLIGENCE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAD.
IT WAS NOT IN ANY WAY USED AS A
BASIS FOR THE INTEL COMMUNITY
ASSESSMENT THAT WAS DONE.
>> Tucker: BUSTED!
LIAR!
BY THE WAY, BRENNAN, YOU SHOULD
KNOW THIS, IS IN NBC AND MSNBC
CONTRIBUTOR, NEEDLESS TO SAY.
TO TOP FORMER INTEL OFFICIALS
DISPUTE HIS CLAIM.
IF YOU JUST HEARD THAT THE
DOSSIER FORMED NO PART OF THE
CORPUS OF INTELLIGENCE USED BY
OUR GOVERNMENT TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HE RETIRED NATIONAL SECURITY
AGENCY MICHAEL ROGERS AND FORMER
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE JIM CLAPPER BOTH
ADMIT NOW THAT THE STEELE
DOSSIER AND ITS CLINTON
CAMPAIGN-FUNDED ALLEGATIONS DID
IN FACT INFLUENCED THE COMMUNITY
ASSESSMENT.
WE KNEW THAT, BUT IT'S NICE TO
HEAR IT CONFIRMED.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY IS SENIOR
EDITOR OF THE FEDERALIST AND SHE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN FOLLOWING
THIS CAREFULLY.
A LOT OF THESE STORIES SEEM TO
LEAD BACK TO THIS GUY, JOHN
BRENNAN.
YOU WOULD THINK IS THE FORMER
HEAD OF THE CIA HE IS SOMEONE
YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO TRUST, BUT
HE SEEMS NOT ONLY A LIAR, BUT AN
INAPT ONE.
AM I MISREADING THIS?
>> WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
MULTIPLE HEADS OF INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES AND THAT DOES INCLUDE
BRENNAN, WHO HAS A HISTORY OF
LYING, SPECIFICALLY ABOUT SPYING
ON AMERICAN CITIZENS.
HIM SERIOUSLY BUT WE'VE ALSO HAD
PROBLEMS WITH FALSEHOODS BEING
SET ALSO BY JAMES CLAPPER, WHO
GAVE INCONSISTENT TESTIMONY
ABOUT HIS LEAKING TO THE MEDIA
AND WE'VE ALSO HAD PROBLEMS WITH
JAMES COMEY HIMSELF, WHETHER HE
UNDERSTANDS WHAT A LEAK IS AND
HOW HE HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN IT.
BUT ONE OF THINGS THAT'S
INTERESTING IS THEY HAVE BEEN SO
MUCH A PART OF THIS STORY AND WE
HAVE SEEN THEIR NAMES A GREAT
DEAL, BUT BRENNAN HAS BEEN ABLE
TO KIND OF STAY OUT OF THE
LIMELIGHT UNTIL RECENTLY WHERE
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO PIECE
TOGETHER JUST HOW INTEGRAL HE
WAS TO THE ENTIRE RUSSIAN
NARRATIVE.
SO FOR INSTANCE --
>> Tucker: PLEASE GO AHEAD.
>> HE ACTUALLY LAUNCHED THE
INVESTIGATION.
HE HAS BRAGGED ABOUT HOW HE WAS
INVOLVED IN LAUNCHING AN
INVESTIGATION.
HE ALSO WAS REALLY KEY IN
BRIEFING HARRY REID, WHICH
HARRY REID HAS SAID HE
UNDERSTOOD THAT HE WAS BEING
BRIEFED BY BRENNAN SPECIFICALLY
SO HE WOULD LICK THAT
INFORMATION AND GET IT OUT TO
THE MEDIA AND ALSO PRESSURE
JAMES COMEY AND THESE OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE INTERESTING BUT
ARE COMING OUT NOW ABOUT HOW HE
CLAIMS THAT THE DOSSIER WASN'T
USED, WHICH MADE NO SENSE
ALREADY BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
DOSSIER WAS USED TO SECURE A
WIRETAP AGAINST SOMEONE IN THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION AND IT
STANDS TO REASON THAT IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN INCLUDED.
BUT NOW WE ACTUALLY HAVE PEOPLE
WHO DO HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
INTEGRITY, PARTICULARLY MIKE
ROGERS SAYING THAT OF COURSE IT
WAS USED IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY ASSESSMENT.
>> Tucker: IT'S BECOMING CLEAR
THAT A LOT OF THE SECRECY
SURROUNDING THESE ACTIVITIES IS
DESIGNED NOT TO PROTECT THE
UNITED STATES FROM FOREIGN
THREATS, BUT TO PROTECT THE
MISDEEDS OF THE PEOPLE GATHERING
THE INTELLIGENCE.
>> IT DOES SEEM THAT THAT HAS
BECOME A BIG PART OF THE
OPERATION.
WHETHER PEOPLE GOT IN OVER THEIR
HEADS, WHETHER THEY WERE LED
ASTRAY BY BRENNAN AND THEY DID
THINGS THAT MAYBE THEY SHOULDN'T
HAVE DONE, IT DOES SEEM THAT A
LOT OF WHAT WE SEEN IN THE LAST
FEW MONTHS IS ABOUT ATTEMPTING
TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM FINDING OUT
THE FULL EXTENT OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
TODAY "THE NEW YORK TIMES" DID
REPORT BASED ON JUST A
WIDESPREAD LEAKING FROM PEOPLE
WHO WERE INVOLVED IN THE
INVESTIGATION THAT, YES, PEOPLE
ARE NOW ADMITTING THEY WERE
SPYING ON TRIM CAMPAIGN IN A
FAIRLY WIDESPREAD FASHION.
IT WASN'T JUST CARTER PAGE, IT
WAS FOUR TOP OFFICIALS.
THEY WEREN'T JUST USING FISA
WIRETAPS, THEY WERE ALSO USING
NATIONAL SECURITY LETTERS AND
HUMAN INTELLIGENCE.
AT LEAST ONE HUMAN INTELLIGENCE
SOURCE.
THIS IS GOING TO BUST WIDE OPEN
AND I THINK PEOPLE WILL DEMAND A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT JUST WHAT
THE FBI AND OTHER INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES WERE THINKING WHEN THEY
BEGAN SPYING ON THE POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN OF A MAJOR PARTY.